all right welcome back to the damn
bungee no show we're here with Michael
Noel's holster the terrific Michael
Noel's show can't encourage you and
strong enough terms to download and
listen to the show it is most definitely
worth your time a lot of lot of deep
stuff goes on in that show he slot
smarter than me confuses me sometimes
sometimes I gotta get the dictionary
and then the thesaurus out afterwards
just to figure out a way to say
something different than Michael just
said
so Michael moving on was a great
conversation about everything going on
with race in America the Statue Wars but
some questions for you about the medium
you know I'm not gonna stereotype all of
them but sadly a large majority the
left-leaning media are interested in as
I say on my show often a story not the
story you know they had one job to get
the facts right they couldn't even do
that it's like being an ice maker who
can't understand you know refrigeration
and freezing kind of an issue do you
have any tips having been so the subject
by the way many of these attacks as I
have from you know alleged media figures
do you have any tips for the audience's
or even the Republican Party how to
break through this media monopoly on the
message out there I'd love to hear your
perspective yeah I mean I think you
totally understand this Dan and you you
know I appreciate the the compliments
that that at the top of the segment but
I do have to say you you have seen a
little bit ahead in in so many of these
instances with the bunch you know report
with parlor without you you've actually
kind of seen where these things are
going so you know I always appreciate
that you can speak in terms that
everybody understands but you you
clearly see what's going on in the media
is really the key here because for
decades and decades the media were the
gatekeepers right so they and in the way
that the media are fake news some people
misunderstand this it's not just that
they publish fake stories which they do
and it's not just that they contradict
themselves day by day which during this
whole coronavirus lockdown has become it
seems to happen by the hour it isn't
just that it's the fact that they are a
corrupt institution broadly it's not
just that one story here there is wrong
it's the way that they select stories
it's the way that they pretend to be
objective it's the way that they pretend
they're just getting to the facts
because they're dishonest they're it
broadly
makes them fake news and so you won't
you will see just total different story
selection between a right-wing outlet
and a left-wing outlet which is why I
think it's helpful to take a little bit
of a look at both but the only way that
we can crack through that edifice those
gatekeepers is by speaking directly to
people social media gave us that
opportunity social media is largely why
President Trump was able to win in 2016
you didn't have to go through CNN you
could go directly to people and that is
why by the way big tech is clamping down
now
major leftists blame big tech for
undermining the media and giving Trump
the election in 2016 and they are damn
sure that it's not going to happen again
so over the next four or five months as
this election increases you're gonna see
more and more people being censored
they're already censoring the President
of the United States on Twitter and I
think that's why he perhaps
the silver lining to this storm Platte
is you're seeing more and more people
moving over to platforms that are not
going to stack the deck against them
platforms like parlor which I just
joined yesterday oh and listen where
he's at Michael J Knowles on parler
follow them stat as soon as you can and
follow my Twitter too I mean the thing
with parlors we're not telling anyone
abandoned Twitter what we're asking
people is make this your social media
home you like to cross post cross post
you want to keep native content there or
you don't do your own thing all we're
telling you is we will not censor you
over there and I appreciate the
compliment as well it's very nice to you
I just I'm you know I'm a doer I just
there's a lot of chatter out there and I
didn't like politics I ran for office I
didn't like the Drudge Report started
Bunji no report I didn't like Twitter I
jumped it on parler so but on your uh
the media commentary you just made yeah
you made a brilliant point I hope the
audience understands here it's not that
they have an opinion everybody has an
opinion everybody's biased everybody
carries bias into what they talk about I
my biases towards libertarian
conservative values I'm sure yours are
the same there's nothing wrong with that
we base it on facts but there is an
understandable bias there I think the
problem with the media as you just
indicated is that they pretend they're
telling an objective story when it's
really in a subjective interpretation of
events and it really just be honest just
be candid we're a left-leaning newspaper
and this is an opinion piece it's not
journalism but they don't do that that's
right they can't do that
and that's that's what makes it so
dangerous in the country because they go
on TV and they've got their nice tie and
their nice jacket and that really
serious face that they practice in the
mirror and they pretend you know that
they're just gonna take the facts and
that that isn't the case I mean I
mentioned it a little bit earlier the
16:19 project this is a news piece from
the New York Times which is they have
all the news that's fit to print or so
they say the central thesis is a lie
the lie is that America was founded to
protect slavery in fact you can read on
the Declaration of Independence they're
complaining about slavery they knew
slavery was a major problem from the
very beginning so it's just it's simply
not true and yet they will publish that
if they're willing to publish a major
feature with a central lie what else are
they lying about what one thing I always
noticed is in the newspaper obviously I
don't I don't know about all the topics
that are in the newspaper but I do know
about some of them and so you read a
story about one topic and you realize
wait a second that isn't true I knit
because I know something about it I know
that that isn't true and then we go on
to the other stories that we don't know
about and we take it to be the gospel
truth that just isn't the case all right
we should apply our own experience here
and recognize when they're getting
something wrong and I think one of the
great achievements of the Trump
administration is he's shown the media
to be the dishonest hacks that they are
and what that means for us it's a little
bit more work we have to look elsewhere
to get our information